Marie Curie's discoveries in radiation
changed the world she became one of the
most important women in science and her
research is still important to
scientists and doctors today she became
the first person male or female to win
the Nobel Prize twice and Marie's
discovery of the element radium helped
unlock the mysteries of the atom yet she
came from the most unlikely of
circumstances Marie Curie showed us that
through hard work and determination
anything is possible
so in this week's bio graphics we meet
Marie Curie scientific pioneer it was
like a new world opened up to me the
world of science maria salami Sklodowska
was born on November 7th 1867 in Warsaw
Poland she was the fifth child born to
vladislav and Brunner flowers Flo dolls
Gunn who were both teachers
Vladislav taught high school physics and
mathematics and although Bronislaw WA
gave birth to five children in eight
years and had tuberculosis she was the
full-time director of a private school
for girls it was only after the birth of
Maria that she finally retired through a
series of bad investments the family had
unfortunately lost their savings
requiring them to board at the private
school where Branislav
had taught this meant that for the
children there was no privacy and they
had to keep quiet and on their best
behavior at all times as it was
mentioned Bronislaw WA suffered from
tuberculosis she was terrified of
passing the lung disease on to her
children so she refused to hug them or
show any physical affection when Maria
who was known as Manya was around five
the family managed to get a place of
their own but they had to take in
boarders in order to make ends meet
Manya didn't have her own bedroom but
had to sleep on the sofa in the dining
room as part of her chores she had to
get up early in order to set the table
for breakfast Manya was fascinated with
the instruments that her father who is a
teacher of physics kept in his little
study especially the electroscope when
she started school in 1874 aged six she
was the youngest and the smallest child
there however she soon proved herself to
be among the smartest of the students in
her class she had an excellent memory so
she was often selected to recite poetry
for visitors this was something
the intensely shy girl absolutely detest
it life in Poland it was tough during
the latter half of the 19th century
Warsaw was under Russian rule law
forbade the speaking of Polish or the
learning of any Polish history however
these laws totally backfired causing
many polls including Manya's family to
be even more proud of their Polish
heritage manye dreamed of doing great
things and bringing honor to their
country when Manya was just 8 years old
her older sister Sophia caught typhus
and died about two years late and
Manya's mother she died from
tuberculosis the nurse'll girl was
inconsolable the two dearest people in
her life her sister and her mother had
been cruelly snatched away from her
despite her despair Manya was able to
maintain top grades at school with the
love and support of her father and
remaining siblings she began to dream
about an accomplished future in 1883 she
completed her high school education she
was the first in her class in every
single subject shortly thereafter though
she became ill with what was called
fatigue of growth and study she spent a
year recovering with her relatives in
the country on her return
Manya was intent on furthering her
education in the sciences but the
Russian government it forbade any polish
moon from attending the University of
Warsaw Manya made a pact with her older
sister branya they would pool their
finances so that first branya and then
Manya could attends the University of
Paris Manya spent the next six years as
governess which meant that she was
little more than a servant to a wealthy
family
for three and a half of those years she
lived with a zorroski family 60 miles
from Warsaw she tutored the children
seven hours a day and was in the beck
and call of the remainder of the family
at all times with the father's approval
she also taught a local peasant children
to read and write and illegal activity
for which she could have been severely
punished
she used every moment of her precious
free time in order to study during this
time Manya also began attending secret
meetings of the floating University
members read about scientific and other
works that were banned by the Russians
because they thought that they might
stir up rebellious ideas after a year of
living with the zorroski family Manya
met their oldest son he was home from
University he and Manya now age 19
quickly fell in love however the
zuransky's refused to let their son
marry
poor governess the unhappy couple
separated but Mannie kept working for
the family because branya was depending
on her in order to pay her way to get
over the heartbreak
Munya threw herself into her studies she
focused on physics and chemistry in 1889
her employments with the zer--aaugh skis
ended and she moved back to Warsaw where
she began working for another family one
of her cousins ran Warsaw's Museum of
Industry and agriculture which was a lab
where Polish students including Manya
could study science by 1891 Murray had
saved enough money for her to join
branya in Paris and it was here that she
actually changed her name to Murray the
French version of her name
living with branya and to new husbands
Murray attended the Sorbonne University
before long was she tired of the commute
and moved into the students area living
in a tiny attic with no proper lighting
and only a coal stove she had very
little money ate poorly and had to pay
for her lessons and worked long hours in
the University Library to do so yet she
found her work so satisfying that the
hardships were worth it to her Murray
had to work much harder than her
classmates due to her limited
understanding of the French language
still she graduated in 1893 having
earned a master's degree in physics she
also got the top marks in her class in
addition she won a scholarship which
allowed her to begin studying for a
second degree this time in mathematics
while studying for mathematics degree
Murray got a job studying the magnetism
of various types of Steel for a French
company to do the work however she
needed to find a lab a friend introduced
her to a man who could help her do so
his name was Pierre Curie a teacher or
an the head of the lab at the school of
industrial physics and chemistry in
Paris he was already famous at this
point for his work with crystals and
magnets Murray began doing her
investigations only different types of
Steel miss Pierre continued researching
the effect of electricity on crystals no
one was more surprised than Curie
herself when he became attracted to
Marie this man of science considered
most women to be a waste of space yet
Marie she was different
she was brilliance and had a deep love
for science instead of wooing her with
flowers
Pierre attempted to steal Marie's heart
by giving her an autographed copy of one
of his physics papers yeah ask Marie to
marry him shortly after they met Marie
wanted to say yes but felt that if she
did marry
yeah she would never again live in her
beloved Poland after completing her
mathematics degree she returned to
Warsaw for a holiday unsure if she would
ever go back to Paris however she was
bombarded with love letters from Pierre
she finally decided to return in order
to continue her education and to CPA
Maria were married on July the 26th 1895
the ever practical Marie wore a dark
blue suit that she could later we're in
the lab for the next year she worked in
Pierre's lab studying steel magnetism in
August 1896 she gave birth to Irene
their first child becoming a mother
though it didn't slow her down she
decided to earn a doctorate in physics
and needed a new topic to study she had
heard about a French physicist named
Omri Beck realm and his discovery of
mysterious uranium rays in 1896 the
subject fascinated her and she decided
to make it the focus of her doctorate in
November 1893 vilhelm wronskian made
German physicists discovered invisible
penetrating rays coming from an electric
tube in one of his experiments he called
them x-rays because we just didn't know
what they were they had the ability to
pass through flesh and other substances
but not through hard dense materials
like bones and thick metals x-rays and
their effects became world-famous within
months in 1896 the French physicist on
Ryba Krell discovered more kinds of
penetrating rays unlike roentgens which
were made by an electrical effect these
rays seemed to come naturally from a
piece of uranium Beryl had left the
uranium lying on a sealed packet of
photographic paper for several days in a
drawer and of course the paper to mist
over the uranium seemed to produce some
kind of invisible rays that could pass
through the thick black paper most
scientists they ignored the uranium rays
but not Marie Curie she threw herself
into the study first systematically
searching for uranium type rays coming
from other elements checking through all
70 elements she found that thorium gave
off Ray's next Marie analyzed rocks that
contained more than one elements as she
expected most of the uranium type rays
were given off by the rocks called pitch
blende
this was because they contained uranium
or thorium but to her surprise
pitchblende
gave off more radiation than she
expected and the question then came to
mind well what was causing this
extra radiation after checking her
results more than 20 times
Maria announced in July of 1898 that she
had found a new elements she named it
polonium after her beloved Poland at the
same time she invented the word
radioactive to describe a polonium
uranium and thorium then in December of
1898 Marie announced the discovery of
another new and even more radioactive
element radium but this was just the
beginning because years of work lay
ahead Marie and Pierre had to prove to
fellow scientists that polonium and
radium existed and to do this they had
to produce the two elements in their
purest forms find the weight of the
atoms and show that each element has an
atomic weight different from any other
element but their first focus it was to
produce pure radium to do this they
needed two things lots of pitch bends
and a large lab the pitch lens came from
a mine in Austria and the Curie's were
able to buy it out very cheaply finding
lab space though that was harder the
only room available was a cold leak he
shared in the air Pierre's work but it
gave them the source that they needed
Marie had to melt pitch blende in huge
pots and stir it with a steel rod almost
as tall as he was despite the hard work
she was determined to discover
everything she could about radioactivity
between 1900 and 1903 Marie published
many papers on her work during this
period she was also completing her
doctoral degree in trying to produce
pure radium as if that was not enough in
1900 she began teaching at a Teachers
College in several Parisian suburb and
of course she was raising her daughter
Irene on July the 21st 1902 Marie
finally reported the weight of one
radium atom this was a major
breakthrough because the weight of the
radium atom was different from the
atomic weight of any other elements it
proved that Marie had indeed discovered
a new element Marie and Pierre could
have become rich by claiming all rights
to working with radium instead they
shared their information telling people
how they'd purified the elements and
much more they believed
scientific research should benefit
everybody
in 1903 Murray became the first woman in
Europe to receive a doctorate in science
but as the fame of the uber science
couple grew their physical health began
to deteriorate Pierre was constantly
tired and in pain and Marie was also in
a constant state of exhaustion she had
recently had a miscarriage and had lost
a lot of weight they both also suffered
from burns numb fingertips we now know
that they were suffering from the
effects of radiation exposure at the
time radium was being touted for its
health benefits because he could kill
healthy tissue doctors tested it on
disease cells and found that it also
destroyed them soon radium was being
used to stop cancer cells from growing
in patients with cancer the new
treatments it was called Curie therapy
in November 1903 Marie and Pierre were
given the Humphrey Davy medal England's
highest award in Chemistry but the
greatest accolade that came a month
later when they along with on Rebeck rel
won the Nobel Prize for Physics the
Nobel Prize came with a substantial cash
award this allowed the Curie's for the
first time to hire a lab assistant now
reporters and visitors they wanted to
meet the famous scientific couple some
eager reporters even attempted to
interview the Curie's young daughter
Irene Nobel Prize winners had to travel
to Sweden to receive their award and
speak about their work but Marie was too
ill to go it wasn't until 1905 that she
was able to make the trip
the couple's feelings about the prize
though they were mixed Marie was proud
of her work and her accomplishments of
being the first woman to achieve world
fame as a scientist the prize money also
helped to fund their research which they
had so far been paying for out of their
own pockets but they dislike to the fame
that came along with the award feeling
that it interfered with their work then
in 1904 Marie gave birth to a second
daughter Eve shortly thereafter pierre
was made a professor at the Sorbonne he
was given better laboratory and Marie
was paid as his chief assistant the next
year he was elected to the Academy of
Sciences
for two yes things went well for the
Curie's they were finally comfortable
financially and we're respected leaders
in their field
then in April 1906 tragedy struck there
just enjoyed a relaxed weekend in the
country and we're back in rainy Paris a
rushed off his feet Pierre was running
errands in the rain when he stepped out
across the road and fell in front of a
horse-drawn wagon the start of horse
reared up and it's he was missed via but
the rear wheels crushed his skull
killing him instantly when word spread
that a famous scientist had been killed
the crowd had to be stopped from
attacking the innocent driver Marie
didn't hear about the tragedy until she
returned home that night she was simply
devastated by her husband's death
however she remembers what he had once
told her whatever happens even if one
should become like a body without a soul
still one must work so when she was
offered her husband's job at the
Sorbonne she accepted before her
first-class reporters students and
curious people crowded the hall to see
the first female teacher at the
Institute they wondered if she would
praise her husband
or break down under the strain instead
she began quietly speaking picking up at
the very spot where Pierre had left off
during his last lecture one of Marie's
deepest regrets was the Pierre had died
without ever having his own permanent
lab it gave a great satisfaction in 1909
when plans were put in place to
establish the radium Institute in Paris
they would have a laboratory that Marie
would supervise and it would be known as
the Curie pavilion working as hard as
ever Marie noted that Lord Kelvin a
Scottish physicist had suggested that
radium was not an element since it had
been found to give off helium gas which
is itself an element she continued to
make even pure polonium and radium by
1910 she had produced pure radium and
showed that it was a brilliant white
metal she even found its melting point
which was 700 degrees Celsius in 1910
Marie also published her 971 page work
treatise on radioactivity and in 1911
came another great honor the Nobel Prize
for chemistry which was awarded to her
alone for making pure radium in 1911
radiology Congress an international
group of radiation scientists decided
they needed a new unit of
for radiation and they call it the Curie
Marie insisted that she was the only one
who could take on the task of working
out the exact size of a Curie unit it
was painstaking work but she did it all
in Pierre's honor in 1911 Marie failed
to be elected to the French Academy of
Sciences many people said that it was
simply because she was a woman
scientific work it was the highest
quality by this point a personal life
was being followed closely by the
newspapers and there was great interest
in her friendship with physicist
colleague Paul long of all extremely
upset by all this attention Marie fell
ill after treatment she stayed with her
friends her fartin in England by 1914
the radium Institute at the University
of Paris was finished the same iya that
World War one began
Marie threw herself into the war effort
she organized extra equipment for
hospitals to help them locate bullets
and shrapnel in the wounds of injured
soldiers she also set up a course to
train people in the use of radiography
units at the war's end in 1918 Marie
became director of the Paris radium
Institute the Institute became a world
center for radiation physics and
chemistry in 1920 Marie became friends
with Marie Maloney an American
journalist Maloney helps to improve
Curie's public image and plan to raise
money for the radium Institute by a
lecture tour in the USA although her
hearing and sight were failing her she
carried out part of the tour before her
illness forced her to return to France
many university is awarded her special
degrees and the women of America gave
her one gram of radium worth $100,000
this was in recognition of her work and
achievements as a female scientist in
1922 she was at last elected to the
French Academy of Medicine in the early
1920s scientists finally realized the
dangers of radiation people working with
radioactive material began taking
precautions but it was too late for
Marie her work with radiation probably
caused the cataracts in her eyes they're
now threatened her with blindness she
had to have four operations to remove
the cataracts but wanted no one to know
she didn't want people thinking she was
old and helpless Marie continued to
oversee the work in her own labs in
Paris she also travelled to raise funds
for research by younger scientists in
1928 she had a final operation for her
cataracts
she was then cared for by her daughter
Eve after further illness she died on
July the 4th 1934 in Switzerland
aplastic anemia a lack of red blood
cells caused by extended exposure to
radiation Marie's legacy it lived on in
her daughter Irene in 1935 her husband
Frederick received the Nobel Prize for
chemistry in 1995 Marie and Pierre were
reburied in the pantheon in Paris she is
the first woman given that honour based
on her own achievements so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
if you did there's a couple of things
you could do right now one is hit that
like button below also if you want more
stuff like this we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching